comes as a Muslim River with Mexican
Roots Islam is a religion that is
growing by the day research from the Pew
Research Center shows that Latino
representation among Muslims in America
is on the rise and start off with you
know Halal you know the way that we
treat animals you know we have to eat
clean and that it came it came from a
movie called Avatar and I'm not sure
that maybe some of you guys have seen it
we have to humanely put an animal down
instead of you know you see you know
videos of slaughterhouses you know just
you know when I told them I was I was
Muslim you know what they said you know
is alhamdulillah in Spanish
on the right path staying away from
alcohol staying away from drugs staying
away from the gambling if you guys look
if you guys have ever been to casinos or
anything like that have you seen videos
of casinos like Islam is Reviving now
and we're basically the backbone
man
and his final Messengers Muhammad peace
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach
when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to you guys and I was
explaining how much respect I have for
the faith of Islam
welcome to the beach
in a former life that's what he was
known by today is Hamza Hamza line of
Allah alhamdulillah
Muslim River with Mexican Roots Islam is
a religion that is growing by the day
research from the Pew Research Center
shows that Latino representation among
Muslims in America is on the rise in
2011 Latinos made up six percent of the
Muslim population in 2017 that number
was up to eight percent and there's a
new study underway right now which gives
us an update on growth Islam found him
eight years ago when he was in a state
of depression
emotional pain
he was seeking Avenues to relieve this
pain but had found no comfort in drugs
alcohol when he reached the bottom of
his life he was hanging by a thread when
he had an Awakening
and his Natural State kicked in
and he was seeking the crater is that
right alhamdulillah that's right
that's right brother salaam alaikum
Brothers
what was that what was that what was
that feeling when you heard me say
depression
when you heard me talk about alcohol
drugs so this is right before you
accepted Islam payment scenario because
we got a lot of people they're born into
Islam as Muslims a lot of times they
think you know the grass is green on
another side and they're jumping over at
all costs and you're running away you're
you're in a deep state of depression
despair paint that picture for us
it's funny because it brings it brings a
lot of uh Memories Back
and it's it's something that actually
Sheikh Guzman was talking about at the
Hupa today
um
something that we hate to go back to and
this pain that I was feeling was you
know just because I was in the Dunya I
was seeking
seeking my own desires seeking my own
pleasure
and
I was trying to find something you know
I guess you can call it a higher fix you
know something to help Elevate me
I could never find it though you know
and then you know life would hit you
with you know calamities with problems
that we deal with on a daily basis but
you know
when when you're not a Muslim you know
and at the time I wasn't very religious
I was I was more agnostic I was raised
Catholic but I was at that moment I was
agnostic you know and I was you know
just trying to live the life
you know
just stuff in the dunion
and I got to a point where it was really
bad where it was
I was killing myself uh with with again
drugs alcohol and you know more you know
that I won't get into but
subhanallah
I got to the point where I had to I I
knew something was wrong and I knew I
had to stop because I knew that this was
this wasn't right it wasn't a good
feeling I know that you know
and you know in Islam you know suicide
is is one of the greatest sins in this
it's basically you know just taking away
your life
so I started seeking you know the truth
and I knew I knew there was something
out there I knew there was you know at
the moment I used to call it you know
the universe the universe was going to
reward me you know I was worshiping the
creation at that time
and I started looking for you know
I was looking back at Catholicism I was
looking into Hinduism into Buddhism you
know everything every isms you can think
of
and you know I had a brother of mine he
actually you know he he would send me
videos he would actually of you brother
Eddie of the dean show and it was uh it
was it was it was very interesting it
piqued my interest I was like okay let's
see what this is about so what I loved
about it was the fact that you would
have you know different Scholars you
would have different stories like how
you have today
of people you know
from different backgrounds from that had
different problems you know people that
had hate in their heart for Muslims you
know and they would talk about their
stories and I'm like you know this is
this is okay I'm getting somewhere with
this
and
you know little by little I started I
started to clean up clean up my life I
started you know getting my act together
I started you know studying about Islam
I started you know reading the Quran I
started reading about the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him I started
reading about all the prophets and then
you know I realized you know as a former
Catholic
um
you know about Jesus Christ peace be
upon him and you know one of the
beautiful things about Islam is is that
we accept all the previous Prophets
and for for me it was it was it was an
easy transition in the sense that you
know my family accepted me as a Reaver
my you know God bless my mother and my
grandmother I love them to death and you
know they're they're Catholic today
uh you know I make Dua for them but they
they've accepted me and they say you
know it when well when I when I told him
I was I was Muslim you know what they
said you know is alhamdulillah in
Spanish you know Spanish in Spanish he
told me alhamdulillah in Spanish
you know exactly what they said anybody
speak Spanish here
so yeah it was it was that that was an
easy transition in that sense but
after you know
this is more for the reverts
a lot of people think that you know when
when you become a revert that it's going
to be a smooth transition all the way
it's not true
you're gonna you know God tells us in
the Quran
that just be just because you think you
believed you think that we will not test
till this day the almighty has been
testing me even you know a couple weeks
ago where you know I was just you know
going through a lot of stuff the old man
the almighty was just bombarding me with
so many problems but all I could do is
say you know alhamdulillah you know this
this is all meant to be there's wisdom
behind this what what am I going to do
about this am I gonna sit here and just
you know go astray or am I gonna
go search go back to my Creator make Dua
ask the Lord to
to guide me on the right path
but you know in between you know I've
been Muslim for eight years now in
between I've had my struggles and I
think this is something that every
reader should know
um and even you know some of the some of
the brothers and sisters who who were
born into Islam and then you know they
they fall off the path is keep your
faith keep your faith strong and just
because you know you're falling off the
path you know just come back to your
creator because at the end of the day
you know Islam this is this is what we
have especially with what we're dealing
with today with all the stuff that's
surrounding us I mean this Dunya I mean
it's not going to last forever and
that's something that we have to kind of
realize but we should never give up
um and again for the rivers don't give
up if if you fall off the path it's okay
get back on get back on track get back
on the wagon ask God for forgiveness and
just keep on going and try to figure out
what went wrong try to figure out what
why was the why was the Lord testing me
what am I going to gain from this what
is the Lord trying to teach me
so just you know praise the Lord at the
end of the day ask for forgiveness and
hop back on
tell me this thumbs up
now you get to a point you start
investigating
you didn't just you were born into a
Catholic Family Christian background and
then you start to experiment with other
religions Hinduism is that right
Buddhism
and
what was it unique about Islam that had
you
get past all these man-made religions
and come to it I know there was a bunch
of different things but what that you
remember if you were getting
go back and think like what was it that
really just struck a chord with you you
know was it the tohe the pure monotheism
was it the deep love of Jesus that we
have and finally you can make sense of
it you didn't have to like have him as a
trinity and this and that what was it
that you could remember that really had
to finally take off for you and you
finally took your shahada
honestly it was it was everyone asked me
every they're always asking this one
question what was the one thing it
wasn't one thing it was everything
everything it was everything that it was
everything that about Islam that was
beautiful to me
you know alhamdulillah you know there is
no God but God that was of course that
was you know that to me made sense
but
the fact that uh
you know we can start off with you know
Halal you know the way that we treat
animals you know we have to eat clean
you know you know God tells us that we
have to sacrifice actually this is
actually kind of something that it came
it came from a movie called The Avatar
and I'm not sure maybe some of you guys
have seen it
there's yeah there's so there's a part
where where uh they're hunting for an
animal
and this this part just kind of struck
me out you know they they sacrificed the
animal and then you know they they they
sacrifice them in a way where it's
painless right
and you know when I found out that Islam
was doing this I was all like that's
that's pretty cool this is this is very
unique because at the end of the day we
have to we have to treat these animals
with respect and we have to thank the
Lord and we have to
we have to humanely put an animal down
instead of you know you see you know
these videos of slaughterhouses you know
just you know killing animals and then
just wasting food and you know that's
something about Islam it's it was the
very little of everything it was it was
very detailed from the small to the
business the small to the big from all
the prophets even you know when I was
like looking in and I never got into
like you know I was I was studying it I
would never I wasn't practicing Hinduism
or Buddhism
um but one of the things that that uh
when I was you know studying Islam
Sheikh Hamza Yusuf he was talking about
how you know and this is you know a lot
of people also mentioned it that there
has been profits since every single
nation so you know you talk about you
know the Buddha you talk about you know
Krishna and so you you start to think
you know you know you know was were
those prophets that you know God said
and you know man made them as Gods so I
started I'm like okay well this this is
starting to make sense the fact that you
know God does send Messengers to every
single nation to teach them away how to
live how to treat your wives how to
treat your brothers and sisters
so today you see a lot of promiscuity
and you see
a lot of people just exposing themselves
and that's the one thing about Islam
that I that I love is is the fact that
you know we we cover ourselves you know
our women cover themselves there's
there's there's modesty I have I have a
I have a baby sister you know she's well
she's not a baby anymore I still call
her my baby sister she's 18 years old
and a couple cousins that they're like
my sisters and you don't want them to be
hounded by a bunch of guys you know down
the street saying you know like hey girl
what's going on you know and I don't
think any of you brothers would accept
that you know that's that's it's it's
just a form of disrespect you know you
want them to have a man to be treated
right and that's what Islam you know
teaches us and even my I mean my
grandmother when she goes to church to
church she actually you know she covers
her head
you know and you know she she does that
that's an example of you know she's like
you know it's an example of mother Mary
you know and you know I tell my grandma
like you know like oh yeah Grandma you
know we believe his mother Mary too you
know
um
so it was it's it's uh
there's again there's just not one thing
that's everything about Islam the Salah
it keeps us on the right path staying
away from alcohol staying away from
drugs staying away from gambling if you
guys look if you guys have ever been to
casinos or anything like that have you
seen videos of casinos you see a lot of
these peoples in the slot machines just
you know like literally sucked in you
know and you're just like wow like you
you know I feel sorry for them you know
and they're just drowning themselves in
debt constantly and then creating
problems within their families and in
Islam you know we're we have to have a
strong family we have to have a strong
household
and that's something that we're losing
today you know and and I feel like Islam
is Reviving now and we're basically the
backbone right now we're bringing you
know especially in America today with
all the problems that we have going on I
feel like us as Muslims as this Zuma
we're we're becoming examples we're
becoming leaders
so you know the Muslims I mean we when I
was you know looking from the outside
and I was like you know these guys
they're they they know what they're
doing you know and they're not giving in
they're not caving in they're not
budging they're not gonna you know just
because you know some someone wants to
be politically correct you know it's
like you go to some of these churches
and you know you have you know you have
pride flags and you have drag queen
shows and you know it's just you know
these perversions that they're allowing
but in Islam I you know I don't believe
we will ever allow it you know and I I
pray to God that it never gets accepted
you know
um so yeah brother it's it's it's a lot
I can go on forever and ever of all the
little details of why I accepted Islam
and I want to thank you for sharing
those
really important pieces of it inshallah
we go deeper to your story but these are
very important you know because other
people especially sometimes we take
things for granted even as Muslims but
someone who went on a journey like
yourself and you had to go through that
to really appreciate what you have now
may Allah keep you steadfast
people benefit from this story
and I'm so excited so grateful to Allah
to be standing right here at the dean
center that is being established in
Tampa by brother Eddie from the dincha
we are so excited that he shows in Tampa
to be this Hub and Center for dawa not
just locally alhamdulillah where we can
host seminars programs dawa activities
there's enough space for a school
gymnasium Masala and a studio that can
inshallah reach people globally to share
the beauty of Islam we're so excited to
have this established here locally in
Tampa and I want to encourage you all do
what you can to help complete this
project and make it a reality and I
invite you all to join me in supporting
the Center of America for all of us to
share the beauty of the Deen with all
Humanity
[Music]
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit
thedeenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you